200 people poetry I can imagine so but
I'm gonna find out
oops people per a tree nope I take it
back I was wrong it looks like it's
largely in between one person and 30
people with a couple exceptions and that
mean it's gonna be pretty interesting on
a graph and I can say the more the
higher the number the worse your
neighborhood is so I'm actually in terms
of because of being um I gotta flip the
dimensions per a green and gray it's
more trees just people and I'll say
people per tree percent number of people
per tree where do people have to share
trees have to share trees
thank you yes that's gonna look terrible
I think we probably want a midpoint
around 10 from what I was seeing maybe
even 15 I'm gonna start with that and
I'll rerun the graph without even having
seen it this is yeah this is really
handy can you all come to work with me
tomorrow uh gray was a bad choice and
throw it back on Brown
I'm scuse me and I don't want percentage
no surprise here the areas you have to
share trees are largely in Manhattan
parts of Bronx as well and looks like a
couple of parts of this weave Brooklyn
this will be Brooklyn and um and a few
areas a few areas in Queens Staten
Island that's not so much we did see
lots of trees relatively low population
density and and yeah that's about what
we expect I bet this is pretty heavily
correlated with with the population
density in general so I wouldn't dumb
put too much focus on it and instead
what I'd rather say is let's look at one
more thing which is trees per area so
tree dent the tree density
tree density tree area what is the
distribution of tree density I mean like
I said my concern here is I don't have a
mental picture of what a of what a of
what density of each of these numbers
really looks like I'd probably rather
have it per square mile which means I
could probably divide it by some 105 to
80 in a mile and you to square that 4
square feet maybe this is right
feel like 2 people why did for 15 in
here there's no way there's 15 trees per
mile is the midpoint was I doing with
this oh I was trying to put this in a
histogram Oh terrible graph I meant to
do that
oh I did it multiply it no one caught
zero people caught that you multiply to
get the trees per square mile zero
people cover it all right wasn't just me
so in between a hundred trees per square
mile and sorry a thousand trees per
square mile and ten thousand so that
means if I make it a graph like this I'm
gonna want to put the midpoint 300 but
I'm also going to want to put it on a
log scale
did they get on my first field let's
find out tree density not even close
ah thank you you notice how everyone
yelled that only when they saw that it
was wrong
nobody zero people were confident like a
few people saw it but nobody was ready
to had to go on the line like Oh David
would have caught it
anyone net I don't see my mistake
I still don't see it I still don't see
it put a midpoint at 3000 log 10 oh
pretty sure that when you do a
transformation you need to transform the
midpoint as well I don't see that one
that's why I'm up here and you're down
there that's better
where are these extremes yeah this is
not people this is number of trees per
per capita and I'd have to flip it the
flip these dimensions back but yeah I'm
gonna wrap this up in a moment but it's
one can you swap trees per square mile
where are
all right this fish is out one of my
remaining questions about where can we
find tree density I didn't get to answer
the question about the relationship
between tree density and tree health but
I want to respect my limits and end it
at a 30 so I'll skip that one it's
definitely one of the but it's
definitely one of the interesting um
questions here we go you know what's
interesting and I think it does kind of
make a sense to me it's that the actual
most trees per square mile are in Upper
Manhattan that really does actually a
certain kind of sense to me you walk
around there you have trees on the curbs
and you have and that is that's actually
really really interesting and Staten
Island is an it does have tons of trees
but it's also pretty large and you're
going to have zip codes like this that
are large and have a relatively low tree
density so that's that's definitely
something we learn from this is that um
trees per square mile probably in people
per square mile
are probably pretty highly correlated so
in conclusion we went through we looked
at a bunch of different graphs we're at
a good chunk of code I said we did three
big topics do we did health we did
health it out and have locates location
we did species and how it relates to
both health and location and we did
density and how it relates to location
as well whenever I finish an analysis
like this I ask questions like what are
the most common kinds of graphs I made
and what can i how can I learn to expand
beyond that and one that I noticed is I
keep wanting to put things on a map so
if I if I had another hour what I
probably would do is make some shiny
interactive shiny dashboards say let's
show a map of New York and let's show
some summary statistics on it everything
from the average health of a tree to the
tree density maybe even the population
density people per tree and so on and
finally if I had more time like I said
I'd probably take a closer look and
we'll add other dimensions in this like
the curb location of the diameter and
how they might relate to health and
species so finally let me say thank you
so much for having me up here it was
such a blast I
this data said I hope you had fun as
well thank you you all say one one more
thanks to Emily for a very pretty this
data stuff together for me
thanks to Jarrod for patching at Bob day
one of otherwise Scott was at the maple
the maple bug yes and a thanks to the
device spatial statistics odd did he
leave
no yes my spatial physics with new
friend over there yes thank you yes and
throw in a barrow count here as soon as
I did that I don't catch the bug I
needed to Oh head doesn't work anymore
oh yeah this is exciting as soon as I
look by a couple of different dimensions
as soon as I look by species common I
can no longer say I want just the top
rose I need the species with the most
rows that makes it uh that means that
instead of using a head I'm gonna want
to use FCT lump
who here is used FCT lump oh you're in
for such a treat so this is one uh okay
so again it's one of my favorites what
I'm gonna do is say FCT lump they don't
know that you can Renate like reinvent
variables with in account that's another
trick that I hear people have learned
from a screencast we say as N equals
fifteen what this says is I still get my
common species but I put all the other
one the remaining ones in a category
other so now I can now I take this to go
a little more aggressive let's say
nineteen and then other I I did that
because I wanted I didn't want the other
to be too big and what I can actually
see here I'm glad I did I did this um
this variation they're definitely
they're definitely our differences by
your region of what types of trees there
are so who here is from the bra who here
sorry is from Staten Island zero people
who is from anywhere besides Manhattan
who's from the Bronx
Brooklyn Queens I'm so mostly Manhattan
in Brooklyn a few exceptions and let's
see in in Brooklyn what we can see is
not a lot of calorie pair and a lot more
a lot of those London plane-trees that
we saw earlier and now to everyone catch
there's the other thing I did is you
have to do a TV order with a some
trailer I can see that we said we don't
have a lot of people from Staten Island
here but it looks like they're fresh out
of honey locust and little leaf Linden
they might have you really see kind of
not as many of in the as you the other
types as you do here
Manhattan looks like they have lots of
honey locusts because we actually so
this actually think is interesting is I
probably would not have expected the
variation to be quite this big it looks
like I like Manhattan doesn't have a
single Norway maple oh why wouldn't we
they look great I think I will
so this was us looking a little bit by
species end and borough it's a pretty
good graph so I'm gonna finish up the
borough and say what species of tree do
you find in NYC that's my second polish
graph I were writing something like a
blog post out of this and the question
we had is how that is I'm I write how do
they relate to health yes
so imagine it's those confounding
factors are probably going to find that
here that tells me we might end up doing
a logistic regression we might end up
doing a prediction of whether tree is in
good health based on both its location
and it's um its species that's a lot
that goes into this this here though I'm
not sure I'm going to start with that
what I do is use the function I've
already defined I'm going to group by
species common and I have my summarized
trees function I don't want to include
any oh but I can probably do do I want
other I don't need other I'm gonna say
we have at least all species where you
have at least I don't 500 trees 71
species
and arranged into Sunday in percent good
health so we find is the healthiest
trees of a sawtooth Oaks very healthy
robust species that one and we see as
the ATC 87% of those are in good health
and if I sort an ascending only 62% of
those Norway maples that we saw the
foreign Norway maple and and that
probably has something to do with
confounded by the locations we saw
earlier that's funny because the Norway
maple there wasn't there weren't any in
in Manhattan so that isn't necessarily
the erection I would have expected most
of them are in Queens and maybe there in
that um that zip code of doom we saw
earlier what's that where we see the
maples we got Norway maple red maple
silver maple and maple Oh vanilla maple
alright and okay so if I want to make a
graph of this there's a graph I like a
lot that I really wish had a better name
the best name would ever come up I've
ever found for it is a bland all I think
it's a bland Dalton plot which is a term
from chemistry but but it's the one
place I've seen where people have really
noted that whenever you have a graph of
something like what are the unhealthiest
trees we care about two things we care
about the number of met species and we
care about the percent good health if I
just asked this question and I noticed
that what sticks out to me is the Norway
maple is both one of the most common
trees and one of the unhealthiest I
probably care a little a little bit less
let's say the Katsura tree which is a
much rarer type of tree even though it
hits my arbitrary cutoff so the plot of
the plot that I use here is I put number
of trees on the x-axis and the
percentage good health the variable I'm
really interested in on the Y make it a
genome point I add annotation text a s
label is the common name of the species
and every almost every single plot you
have with a magnitude in the x-axis is
need your scalex log10 I'm gonna try
I'll try this if you just as 1h just as
one check overlap true I'm pre polishing
my graph a little bit
I want to avoid lots of overlap the
reason I like this kind of graph is is
what sticks out to us is the most
extremes we probably don't care a lot
about whatever this is called The Tree
of Heaven that um that's one of the
rarer types and not quite as unhealthy
we're interested in both what is what is
the least often measured as an in good
health
like the Norway maple where we notice
the Sawtooth oak yes its unusually
healthy but it's not particularly common
so there isn't any one incredibly
healthy kind of tree but there are a few
that are typically unhealthy and well
they're really all maples that's
interesting but is it signs up with them
maples and um this isn't a graph of
polish too much but I probably would add
labels , to the to the x-axis and while
I'm at it let's say number of trees in
NYC percentage marked as in good health
that's the vision that's good health and
this I like to stick out a few are a few
questions what is up with the maples I
can't resist I really don't like leaving
a that's been what's up with maples with
a few ways we can attack that question
we can start by by separating the maples
a square where are the maples we can ask
now kind of like a scan where the maples
wants to find out where all the maple
trees are in the end what in New York
City who knows they have a maple tree
near them where they live I think I have
any maple trees maybe and maybe in the
park dennah the department well you know
so we're gonna look up our maple trees I
have a species column here and I'm gonna
count how often does the word
maple appear in it so if I do string
detect string to lower the in the
species common maple we find most trees
are not maple some as we saw before I'm
missing what I could what I'll do is add
a column called maple that's boolean
true or false and what I'll do is one
one more thing I'm gonna take this put
it in my processing step because maybe I
want to use it in other questions that I
answer and I'll even throw into my
summary function I'm jumping around a
little bit mean specie Amin of maple and
IRM equals true so if I now group by
bear by borough I can find out where the
maples are who thinks the most maples
are in Manhattan a by percentage have a
Queens I'm kind of guessing Queens let's
find out what we have most maples are in
Staten Island by a large margin
alright and see this also makes me ask
the question does are maples equally
unhealthy across across boroughs so I'll
do is actually aggregate by maple as
well makes that filter not is an a maple
alright and we actually find in here I'm
gonna let me see because I'm gonna do
I'm gonna make a scatterplot of this I
want to compare the health of maple and
non maple within each borough and that's
what I mean a little bit of Tidy are
magic what I'll say is if it's maple
maple other and summarize trees never
know what would I miss him
filter not is in a maple I did but I
wanted to do that oh thank you yes oh
that's a yep that would be that was
rough
yes so it's because of the summarize
function of the summer I added to the
summarized function and what I need to
do is actually select just the Bureau
the maple and the percent good health
and tidy are spread them we need to
reshape that data so I can make the
graph that I have in my head and the
graph that I have my head has other and
mate on the x-axis and maple on the
y-axis and probably a nice gene a red
line going up the x equals y line so
maples are unhealthy wherever they are
at a throw in a genome text I didn't
know how that was going to turn out and
it's interesting to see I'm gonna expand
I'm also gonna start my limits at x
equals 0 and y equals 0 yeah
too much we see that that there all that
um in each borough that we can look at
there are that the trees are unhealthier
the maples aren't healthier probably
especially Manhattan but that means not
necessarily about being confounded with
um with location but I ask the question
where are the most maples and that so
that I can go back to the same graph
that I've done a graph that I did before
we do it trees by zip code which now has
our percentage of maples it is and in
the end I can probably almost reuse this
exact code I can say I still have my
join trees which I'm going to separate
out
I find a copy-paste code a lot when I'm
doing this especially cuz I don't know
what's interesting and I want to keep
all the graphs that I'm making sometimes
you can split them in a function but
functions but you can't always I'm here
I'm gonna say percent maple the midpoint
probably needs to be lower I don't know
how low but we're gonna but we're making
the exact same graph otherwise only now
it's gonna be percentage of trees that
are maple
where are the maple trees in NYC and a
rerun this a second my threshold is to
my midpoint is too high we saw a thing
that the largest fraction of maple trees
was in it was in Staten Island let's see
what it looks like on a graph now had
that's super interesting so not only was
it cannot confounded by um by location
but in fact it kind of went the other
way we see maple trees are generally on
healthier but we don't see maple trees
in general in Manhattan we also don't
see them in this area where the where we
saw the overall really bad health
instead we find them in Staten Island we
find them out in eastern our Queens we
find them even in parts of the Bronx and
that's interesting so that's actually
interesting cuz it goes in the other
direction it doesn't mean it it's
certainly not impossible but that's
something we found out about um maple
trees today that sounds that sounds
right yeah see alright so that was me
answering the question that the
remaining question of specie of um how
might species be related be related we
first took a look at this graph look at
took a look at few graphs we look at the
most common species of trees then we
took a look where we found that the most
common are plane trees locusts etc we
see a few maples in here and then we
looked at what percent what are the ones
this um graph that has a number of trees
in the x-axis and the health of trees on
the y
and we see that the Maples really stand
out in fact if I remake excuse me when I
make this graph now I probably want to
say color equals maple really trying to
emphasize do we can we see this um I
forgot to oh yeah sort of throw the
group I we actually see as yes most may
types of maple are both common fact yet
these six types that are really common
and also really generally less healthy
stand out and then we took a little so
that was the second part of that a
question we saw that in that in fact
maple trees aren't healthier no matter
where they are it's not just their
confounded with location that was on
this plot and then we finally saw that
that we made a map of where are the
maple trees actually and we see
something interesting about them and
where they're on where they're located I
don't have more questions or tree about
the species and and health I feel like
we answered that one pretty well so yeah
that's all great so would we be on so
we've covered this topic and I'm gonna
spell about 15 minutes left and I think
that's a great idea for one is asking
the question about trees trees and
people we are actually three dimensions
we have area people and trees so fuse we
can do that we can do it population
density tree density where we can do
trees per capita who wants to take a
look at that in the last 15 minutes all
right so now we'll add one more section
why say looking at tree and population
density
I like this joined trees dataset because
I'm from now while we're mostly going to
be looking by zip code and I'm really
interested in questions we can answer by
zip code in particular I'll need to look
at a couple of distributions I'll say
what's the distribution of population
almost every single distribution of
population is better looked at on a log
scale where you see there a few zip
codes where we have very few people I
suppose
and most fall between 10,000 and 100,000
people but what I'm really interested
pop more likely as population density
which is population divided by area I
don't know what the unit of area is yet
I'm actually gonna graph that one first
what unit do we think area is in this in
this data set this is not from the
original trees data set it's from a
separate open one that I downloaded but
we looks like it maxes out at what is
that a hundred million bits square feet
visit its let's see this whoo all right
I see area I don't see it
it just says area whoo I don't see it I
don't owe us feet so we will take it as
square feet all right
people for per square feet how what's
that well what's that distribution look
like population per area generally
one-tenth of a person per square foot
that's um since I'm about the density of
my apartment so I would have 100 the
rehearsin preferred yes
so I'm my wife gave me a look like no
but yeah what I'm going to do is add
population density and I'll add a second
tree density and that's trees divided by
area and a lot of third which is trees
per capita trees per population
and I'll call this is simply called
process zip codes these zip codes with a
little extra data add it in what zip
codes have the most trees per person I'm
gonna select the interesting columns
there are a lot of them here and
population area and everything I'm
actually gonna do that up here I bet it
didn't like oh yeah trees circle and
yeah so if I look now at processive
codes and I arranged by descending tree
dense trees per capita was the
interesting one is there anywhere trees
out number of people who thinks there
are zip codes which freeze our number of
people in New York oh man let's find out
infinity trees for people all right that
one worked out but I filter population
good I ought to say probably want more
than a thousand people it's not flying
out very meaningful
it looks like there's one where we found
where there's about two and a half
people per tree we will do capita per
tree on this scale people actually I'm
gonna do that
I'm gonna call it people per tree I'm
gonna rename that I like the idea of how
many people have to share one tree
it's New York we're gonna have to share
sleep share transit yeah your treat
so there's um so for example I could
filter for zip code I don't like these
caps I'm going to throw in a quick
rename all string to lower rename all is
super handy for running something on
them all your fields and through them
and now I'll say filter population zip
code equals equals and start with mine
in my neighborhood you have 228 people
have to share one tree somehow shout out
their neighborhood one won't you and
where is that
and hmm we threw in it has two columns
here that's all it's a shapefile that's
gonna be a shapefile region thing but it
looks like oh yes they have nine people
only nine people have to share treat now
I say when I was moving to Brooklyn
exactly and I'm really into I'm actually
really into these um these these columns
so I'm gonna make one more graphics
really can't resist making graphs but
it's so much so that I'm gonna throw
these columns back into this joint trees
step and bring in one more let's see
where did I do my where did I do my last
map set of trees here it is
and look at for a moment where are the
jail my column yes I do trees per people
per tree people per tree what's the
distribution of people per tree I bet
you it's gonna need to be on a log scale
almost everything like this is because
you have you have large variations some
probably Sheriff making people feel good
or bad about their zip codes first so
who do you think is the healthiest trees
San Island let's find out so when I did
is instead of grouping by postcode I'm
in a group by both postcode and borough
so now we get to bring in the Manhattan
data and now I can actually oh it's your
son I can do I can probably like a
boxplot by zip code I could do it a few
ways but I think I might just look at
the top few so arranged in descending
trees the top four are all in Staten
Island but what if I arranged in
descending order of average health who
thinks the healthiest trees are going to
be in Manhattan sparse smart move who
thinks the healthiest resume in Staten
Island
Queens Brooklyn
what's the one I forgot the Bronx want
if you don't guess you have any chance
of winning that car alright let's let's
find out we're arranging in first
descending order of average health so
the healthiest borough with an average
2.9 one that's pretty impressive is the
healthiest to iron Queens but that
doesn't actually answer the question
overall about average health notice that
I've got this aggregation I do here
summarize average health I bet I'm going
to be doing more of it I'm gonna write
my own my first function my function is
going to be called summarized trees my
first function today not my first
function
this would not be the time to learn what
I do is I realized that I'm going to be
doing this kind of aggregation a lot and
I am me see yeah I'm gonna I'm gonna
leave the filter outside of it summarize
trees and this is by zip code but this
also gives me ability to say look at my
trees group them by
burro you noticed that I've never once
spelled burro cravat without hit the
help of autocorrect and I summarized it
and boom Manhattan goes down the
healthiest trees are in fact in the
Bronx all right and Manhattan is the
lowest by a solid margin so um we had a
couple paths we can we can do here who
wants to make a map nobody wants thing I
want to make a map who doesn't want to
make a map who's not gonna raise their
hand no matter what I asked you know who
you I guess I guess that I answer my own
question there all right so we're gonna
make a map and to do that I need to
remember a lot of things they need to
remember how to grab zip code shapefiles
NYC we're in good shape here at in Weiss
and NYC definitely easier than we would
be in a lot of other like I wouldn't
necessarily know how to do it for even
necessarily New York State but I bet
we're in good shape on this one let's
see what we got
uh-huh okay shapefiles anyone here
worked with um shapefiles and ggplot2
before I think I have like I used to do
it a lie you stood a bunch when I was a
god maintaining the broom package we're
gonna find out how much I remember but
it's good but this means I don't have a
lot of help from the audience we're
gonna find out
so shapefiles let's see Rita Saif I like
the sound of that what package is that
in alright do I have SF we used to have
tidy rows for SF
boom package but that was a few our
installations ago looks like I have it
does that read underscore SF read SF
that looks good alright so what I'm to
do is downloads and what it like what
was the file called zip code zero zero
one four and where's the SF file you
give it the rectory who this knows that
was really good
thank you everything around and plus my
help from the audience alright so this
tells me is this is these are my zip
codes and I like how I really like how
tidy that is but what I'm curious about
is can I get it in there ggplot2 there
used to be a function called fortify
then we have tidy what's the class of my
zip codes
it's an SF and at the end the table I
like I like the sound of this the my way
with you
giome SF is this going to plot them but
how am I gonna be able to fill it what
I'm thinking of is if I can't I do this
if I can take the polygons and bring out
their um their longitudes and latitudes
then I can join this data set with the
tree with the aggregated by zip one but
I'm going to try I can join but I could
definitely join but am I gonna be able
to fill may be alright we're gonna try
that we're definitely try this together
so if I've got my zip codes and I've got
my by zip code I'm gonna call it trees
by zip code to separate it from the
other data that I'm looking at say I do
I'm trying to rename meaningfully here
we go one of the challenges you might
have noticed so far is that I we still
have post codes one exception it looks
like all of them are five digits so I'm
just going to go ahead and say post code
is as character of post code read our
thought it was a number but it's um it's
not and I'm gonna now take zip codes
inner join it nope left join it because
I want to keep I probably want to keep
zip
don't have any trees in them with my
trees by zip code data set which I still
need to rerun and it's called zip codes
here all right by zip code equals post
code was what I think it was called ID
and average health trees oh that looks
good so what just happened was I'm going
to view this is it gonna crash our I
haven't saved once I went no one was
gonna call me out on that not new it not
actually new enough it's been a couple
months
I keep seeing people with these great
features that I don't have access to so
this is really cool what it did is is
I've got the zip codes got information
oh I've officially the population well
that's really handy because it means
actually I could do things that compare
population to the number of trees and
here I've got the geometry so now I've
got that what value a want average
health and all the information that I
probably want in terms of the shapes so
this is my map data this is my tree data
and 263 zip codes I'm gonna try plotting
it I heard someone say genome SF
definitely I definitely do that that bit
next oh it doesn't like this one so much
let me try Oh III didn't even do it with
the left join no no usual oh that's
usually just a you rerun it in our
studio one anything yes I'm gonna round
applause to everyone who helped me out
on that one
here's my joined trees I had I wasn't
actually using the join trees and I feel
pretty good about this if I say fill
equals that start just with number of
trees then I could probably plot this
there's a theme we use theme map it I
believe comes from Jiji themes the
polygon edge not found is just in our
studio usual thing that'll pop up this
is a theme map I know how I feel about
that how does I don't know how I feel
about the grid but other than that this
is really pretty handy we're seeing is
one thing we learn is this this data set
does not include trees in Central Park
I think that makes a lot of sense who
wants to count every single tree in
Central Park I don't know if it includes
other parks like I don't see a lot in
Riverside so it's a park near where I
live and here let me see yeah but what
we've seen is largely at the large areas
have more parks so this is so we noted
it's Staten Island had the most trees
but it definitely did not have the
highest density of trees or there's no
reason to believe that it did and
actually now we have some information on
density of zip codes that we didn't have
before in our first dataset so we're
going out and finding the zip code data
which I'm actually gonna bring into a
new chunk we were able to UM we were
actually able to bring in information we
didn't have before so we've got genome
SF but before I look at back of those
questions I really want to say where are
the healthiest trees we map and I try
theme void which is just built in I'm
not so sure I love these these grid
lines fill is average health and find
out where the healthiest trees and the
unhealthiest trees are
oh wow what is happening here there is
one zip code does anyone know what this
area is oh yeah well like they don't
look like they're doing a very good job
so I don't do a lot of spatial
statistics work but I feel like I said
there are some correlations we can see
here largely like we look out here to
the east and I'm in Queens and we see
that there's sort of healthier and then
sort of gets unhealthier around around
Manhattan we'll get an average health
here weren't the more I think about it
the less average health feels like quite
the right metric I think given that
distribution that we saw earlier in the
genome call we might have wanted to do
percentage good I kind of like that as a
um as a metric I'm gonna leave I'm gonna
leave in average health and say percent
good health and I can do a trick where I
say mean of health equals good and get
the fraction from that I feel like now
that I'm doing this this analysis I
probably want to leave in some of the
even though zip codes that have fewer
trees and oh thank you and I are I'm
true yeah we can see like general v's
are going to be correlated the average
health the percent that are in good
health but I can remake my map and say
percent good health
it's going to be very similar I've
resized at the wrong moment I think one
thing I notice from this is that I'm
gonna want to polish this plot there's a
pretty good plot well when it shows up
it'll be a good plot which means we can
code while we wait for it that's um
that's a good strategy which means I'm
not crazy about this scale Phil I really
like scale fill gradient too greedy
who's your scale feel gradient too
before I don't know what you're missing
the low this lets us say we want low red
high green yeah I was the complete
sadism towards the colorblind people in
the audience I guess um I do I do like
that so like what would it be dark green
dark green not it's like a big dark
green red real tacky brown oh boy that's
a good one let's see how this looks and
we also get to throw in midpoint is I
like I could say midpoint is 0.7 but I
want one other thing in here which is um
which is while I'm polishing the graph
I'm gonna want to thought I had a theme
void what happened to that what are
these lines maybe it's a Geo messin up
then I could probably what's that cord
SF and datum equals it so what do you do
it shows nice datum equals na awesome
and labels are our scales percent
because we are looking at percentages
here
hmm one issue we run into is that almost
everything is healthy except for these
few that means I don't want the midpoint
to be 0.7 I might want the midpoint to
be I don't know
85% how many trees in your neighborhood
would you feel comfortable not being
healthy so we do 85% yeah I like it a
little better without the coordinates
now every our boy that's a dark
that's not very uh try making the green
a little darker golden blue high gold
low it is but I almost forgot how to use
it and I know this one's not too bad
this is pretty uh this is pretty cool so
what I'm actually going to do is finish
up this graph with a labs fill equals
percentage good arm trees in good health
and say out of the title
I love making questions for titles where
are the healthiest and unhealthiest
trees in NYC and I'll say based on 2015
survey on a 2015 survey of six hundred
thousand trees subtitles I'll every good
graph has a subtitle
so God
oh man what's happened with my cords I'm
gonna throw back in cord map
I don't you really got to be careful
when you do Oh nope it doesn't like it
here's a question was that did I look
warp to anyone else looked a little
warped to me but did co-opted a care of
that let's find out all right yeah
that's actually that looks this looks
great to me so time is let me see I've
been talking for about 35 minutes and we
finished our first polished graph this
is a graph by zip code of of the
healthiest trees the earliest healthy
trees if you like trees probably don't
live in Manhattan and thank you very
much but that was Julia that was just
the first graph so we were going to do a
second one I am really uh this is
usually the point in analysis where I
where I would stop and ask - where do we
want to go net what kind of question do
we want to answer next an example now if
I really hadn't found anything
interesting on health it probably would
have stopped here I'm somewhat
interested I'm already got I'm pretty
interested in the zip codes on health
and I've realized there's things I want
to know I want to know why the Upper
East Side has less healthy trees I want
to know why some other areas here within
here look like I'm certainly really
curious about the wetlands but um what's
that oh man sandy in 2012 so we think
that was sign that that was signed to do
with it could be and this makes me so
this makes me interested in in answering
these health questions and I also have
questions about about population density
so when I joined this dataset together I
I took our trees and I um and I combined
them with information about population
and area which means it's easy for me to
get in population density so I didn't
start looking at as population density
and maybe I can look at tree density do
those correlate do those are they
negatively correlated
and how to each of those relate to
health that's one question that's on my
mind
second question that's on my mind is to
start looking by things besides just is
it measured in good health questions
like questions like what is the ad what
is the typical diameter or what's the
what are the ones we had here John what
are the most weak Wow dammit we could
ask question about their damage we could
ask questions about what the common
problems in trees are oh and this
requires some some what we were we call
it up separating I'm nesting so that's
another interesting question and we have
these questions of these common problems
roots stone root create trunk wire
probably other issues but I'm alright
what what I would say is is there three
routes I see forward one is
investigating questions of diameter and
how they might relate to parts of the
city and health another that I might
investigate is common problems maybe
also how those correlate with health and
a third that I mentioned that I might be
interested in is population density so
how does population density relate to
tree health so I'm somewhat evenly torn
between those three so I'm going to
leave it up to the group is they don't
have a separate question that they're
interested in from this data usually
what's that user type
that's good question it could be a
confounding factor of who'd was it who
I'm counting it what if one group was a
little had different standards than
another that's another question so
species and health may be yes okay I'm
losing track of all the questions but
let's work our way backwards who raise
your hand if you want to analyze species
and health solid amount for a species
who aren't is interested in the user
type how people who's interested in the
common problems trunk light branch
lights stones it's pretty close to the
first one and who is interest
population and tree density I think the
winner is a species is that right if
you're just sayin species give me a
round of applause
yes so let's start by let's start
looking at species I'm probably going to
make a map at some point cuz I really am
glad I set up these um these zip codes
and I'm going to want to do that some
more what I do what I look at is uh
let's see trees and I anytime I see a
categorical they're categorical variable
like trees I'm gonna want to count so I
look by I don't look at SPC common all
right I've got London plain tree honey
locust calorie pair pin oak and um yeah
and we have some missing data I'm gonna
throw in a filter quit anyone possibly
get me a cup of water and I ran out and
I'm talking a lot is na SPC common
anytime that I have a graph like I got
count like this people that I work with
or watch my screencasts know that I
really love this kind of graph right
what I always do isn't gonna make a bar
plot probably do this in my sleep right
now what I'll do is a reorder the
elements in it the species common FCP
reorder by by n make a plot coordinate
and I find the most common species one
day I'm also curious about is do we have
a really long tail of species it makes
it's good news to me that there's a
couple types that are really really
common like the London plane to London
plane tree plane tree it looks like a
looks like every other tree I've seen in
my life
but it I all right but and followed by a
honey locust Cali pear honey locust
honey locust tree oh yeah that's the
other kind those the children I usually
keep this plot here I'm gonna spin back
up to the top and set my theme theme set
theme light it's all my favorite themes
and I go I'm not gonna polish this one
as much but I usually would remove the
x-axis the y-axis number of trees in NYC
and I'm curious about one last thing
here while we're making a bar plot where
we're using a lot of wasted space on
this color I'm gonna throw in a fill
equals verb so it's an enormous honor
for me to be at this Meetup I've really
appreciated all Jared support throughout
the years I've really loved being at the
New York our conferences I'm gonna have
to miss this um this year gonna be on
vacation but definitely go for all the
great talks including my sister Emily
who helped me prepare for tonight so I'm
a data stream data side as a data camp
and like a lot of scientists I like to
run experiments so this isn't today is
an experiment where I'm gonna try
analyzing a data set that I've never
seen before so it's it's an experiment
that I've practiced for a little bit
last October I started doing screencasts
where it analyzed data live record my
screen and isolate I'd never seen before
and see um and see what I could what
kind of graphs what kinds of insights I
couldn't learn from it I want to
discover it is it's a fantastic way to
teach and I really I really really like
teaching are I like teaching how to pull
apart data sets I like trying to
communicate how I think and I've
discovered it's one it's is one of my
favorite ways to do it but I've never
done in front of an audience before and
I'm really excited about that
is everyone ready excited all right
so I couldn't have done this without the
help of my of my brilliant sister Emily
she's also a data scientist I definitely
see it like I said see her at the New
York our Meetup and what she's done is
curate three data sets from friends and
colleagues of ours that so I don't even
know the topics of what I'm gonna be
analyzing I've downloaded this but I've
never opened I have the data set or
these slides so we're gonna find out
together what kinds of data sets we
might be analyzing but everyone give a
round of applause for Emily for helping
where's Emily yes so I'm gonna start by
opening this all right so it looks like
these are the three data sets so we have
a salary survey so 21,000 responses to
an anonymous salary survey so it looks
like some of the questions are like how
old are you what industry is this you
see
that's cool this is this is great all
right so the first dataset is gonna be a
salary survey the second one is movie
lenses yes so it's gonna be a hundred
thousand ratings um and tags on movies
by six hundred users with tags like
looks like funny or highly quotable and
the third one is the New York 2015 tree
survey so data on six hundred twenty
eight thousand trees including the
location type diameter and health and a
total of forty five columns Wow so this
is um this looks like three really
exciting data sets we're gonna let the
audience choose which of them I'm going
to analyze
I got you all right so we got a we got
some columns here and then looks like
all these columns here including some
free text it looks like this one has
some cameras and tags and then and this
one has um looks like a lot more
information about trees that we can only
find out by opening it so who wants to
analyze the salary survey maybe raise
your hand I love the clapping I love the
enthusiasm as your hands who wants to
analyze the movie data set who wants me
to analyze the trees all right trees it
is I want to find out these forty five
columns fantastic so I have yet as we
see I have um so Emily where did the um
where did the who gave me the tree data
set fantastic well Shirley's going to be
winning a free copy of my book text
mining with our that would be forever no
yeah it's great it's a great day for
data set all right so these let's see
all right so this one is called 2015 all
right sorry I just I've unzipped it I'm
opening up our studio who here uses our
as their primary programming language at
the same to see who for whom here who
here hasn't used our before also there's
gonna be I think there's gonna be a fun
experience for everyone
alright so I'm gonna open up an arm D
where I usually do my analyses I'm gonna
try zooming in a little bit this looked
like it's about the right text looks
good ribbon alright I almost always
start by loading up the tidy verse go
and let's start by reading in the data
set I'll do read CSV and it's on my
desktop in data set ideas 2015 Street
here we are tree data so it's a big one
oh look at that go and I didn't even
save it to an object here we go nothing
like the smell of a new data set
opening it up in a view seeing what are
these 45 columns
oh wow oh this is gonna be great
alright so alright what I start by
seeing is looks like we have one row per
tree they're identified in blocks I
really I really wonder if we have on
location data here so we can make a map
that would be an exciting thing to thing
to do what I see is let's see a lot of
categorical columns and then a group of
columns here that are yes/no that tells
me I'm gonna be using the tidy verse
gather to work with these because
they're in a wide format rather than a
tidy one we have an address I don't
really have oh good we have zip codes I
was thinking like I don't have really
the time to geolocate 680,000 trees this
is this every tree in New York and we
also have the zip code the zip code is
associated with the zip city and more
information like borough I'm definitely
not going to get to every single column
but um I'm something's probably gonna
ask the audience for opinions about
where should work latitude and longitude
that's what I was hoping to see in some
tree data and um council district and I
don't know what all the remaining
columns mean I'm definitely I said going
to use only a subset what data do we
have about the tree we have its stump
diameter but I immediately see a lot of
those are zero we've got to watch out
for like stump diameter tree DBH
sometimes i go i go and i search this um
I'd search inspiration now sometimes
this would come with like a data
dictionary I don't have one here because
we this data is brand new to us I'm
sorry yes but I can't probably look it
up by saying 2015 Street Street tree
census and then throw in the name of the
column tree DBH does anyone know what
DBH would stand for any tree experts
here yeah I mean what's that address
nice thanks alright so then we have and
it looks like stump diameter is gonna be
missing a lot that's saying to know who
wants to find out which boroughs keep
the best their trees in the best shape
it's
let's go Manhattan let's go Upper West
Side all right and we have status and
health we have a species in Latin and a
common name all right
usually when I see categorical columns I
know that I want to count them like I
really like to see what the most common
versions are ones are it's gonna I'm
gonna pick a couple of these and I'm
gonna count them I'm gonna say let's see
tree data set my first question was was
I really want to count by barrel what
did it say what was it called it was
called zip city ah and also Barrow
things up with my thank you Thanks so
that's the kind of thing that's yes okay
I never would I would have taken ten
more minutes on if I've been doing a
screencast tree data set all right
the only boroughs we have are your five
New York boroughs most are in Manhattan
nope
fewest in Manhattan that bet it makes it
that makes a lot of sense and I'll see
most in Queens if I look by zip city
what am I going to find how does it
divided down so Brooklyn Staten Island
Bronx New York but then we have looks
like they broke down Queens but not the
other boroughs so it makes it a little
bit less useful we can count by zip by
what was it called postcode all right
and all right my postcode is 1 0 0 2 3
anyone else got um zip codes here
someone else yell at your zip code 1002
what is that new Chelsea all right so
we've tied for almost tied for number of
trees anyone else got a zip code
in not equals anyone else catch that all
right so I'm beat it so in a void side
of a belt tied with where's one zero
zero zero two what's that Lower East
Side and Upper West Side and Stuy Town
all right we'll start with those and one
thing let me see one thing I mentioned
before I'm curious about is tree health
by Bureau I'm gonna start just with
those three boroughs
what does tree health look like we had a
column called read a column called
health fair good one at else we have
tree data set count tree health was it
called health health fair good poor
missing all right so if I filter out not
is n/a I want make sure I have enough
data first I still have plenty of data
from each of these and if I count it
instead of by both postcode just
postcode buy postcode and health I start
getting the number of the add each on
stage and this is actually a perfect
chance for my first graph so I'm gonna
do is say we have on the x-axis is
postcode but not really
hmm no on the x-axis is health because
on the y-axis is M and we make it a bar
plot and we faceted split it up into
individual sub graphs by postcode so the
reason I did that is I wanted to see
what the distributions are between fare
good poor not the right order that I'm
looking for here so gonna quickly set up
to do an extra step of cleaning on my
data set I like to do this up here when
I'm setting up the data what I'll do is
say tree data set raw and then I'll
create my tree data set part of typing
tree data set I'm gonna call it trees I
think it's gonna make it maybe a little
bit easier for me to stop getting typos
on it and what I'll do is say mutate
I've got four cats loaded so what I'll
say is health is FC tre level the I'm
not I'm I want to say that fair health
is going to be poor
then fair then good I doing that up here
so I don't have to keep doing it step
every single time now we see the
distributions between these three
Manhattan boroughs it doesn't look like
there's too much difference maybe yeah I
kind of like that yeah the Upper West
Side looks like it's winning by a little
bit of a margin so if I want to
otherwise aggregate that so I could do
would be to say what's the average
health by borough so I've got my three
boroughs here I'm gonna separate this
out a little bit I'm gonna say three
boroughs and I'm gonna filter it before
I do the count so notice what I did is
I'm actually taking my three boroughs
that I'm doing the analysis here now I
couldn't count it and see these
distributions of poor fair and good most
of the time not poor Autry's or I could
say what's the average health where we
gave them a score from one from say zero
one two the way that I can do that is
say group by zip zip zip code posts code
just use that and summarize average
health if you're an average health I'm
going to need to do as numeric on the
health column so because I've turned it
into an ordered factor back here that's
gonna work out kind of well for me and
we find out oh I didn't do it on my
three boroughs and I didn't say na are M
equals true so here we go and yep I was
right the healthiest between these three
boroughs was was the Upper West Side and
if I if I'd lost they were upset oh it
doesn't matter but I'm definitely
psyched it went my way so I just did I
just did this on three post as if codes
but what if I did it on all of them well
anytime I do it are now on every single
oops I wanted to still want to group by
postcode but I want do it on all the zip
codes that we have so now I have data on
every single one and every and every
time
do this notice that it didn't know that
it's not a number so looks like a few
and 0 0 0 8 3 anytime I do an
aggregation like this I'm gonna also
want the number of trees you don't want
to include zip codes that have very few
trees if I arranged in this in ascending
order of the number of trees yup seven
trees nine trees can't do anything with
that I'm going to filter for trees I
don't know at least a thousand the ones
I was looking at before all had a
thousand well maybe to find out I'm
gonna graph it in a histogram looks like
I was kind of expecting a longer tail
than this it looks like they're only a
few zip codes anyone have a guess for
what zip code has the most trees or what
Bureau it's in we're thinking in Queens
well we saw the Queen's are the most
trees so I think that's probably a safe
bet but I'm gonna set a threshold of a
thousand I think it'd be a fewer than a
thousand it might not be worth the the
the analysis so I'm gonna throw an F
filter I do that hmm
is that is that true alright I'm excited
I decide to find out so um by zip code
we've done an aggregation and now we
have an announced by zip code of both
the number of trees and the average
health I'm gonna arrange in descending
order of trees to find out if Jared's
right anyone recognize this zip code and
nobody lives here let's find out if it's
Flushing Meadows it's Staten Island so
let's see I do the map of this or
anything I find when I analyze well I
get to look at some homes do you see
trees in these homes I don't see trees I
don't know but 22,000 trees in that in
that borough this place to be what do
you mean
maybe it's just what so you mean maybe
they're like really young we should take
a look at the day at the age in the
diameter but let's that's a good rule so
that that would matter a lot so let's
take a look at the question is are there
do we have tree ID here but are there
duplicates such as over time that means
we can do a sort true fingers crossed
let's not have a bunch of good news so
every tree only appears once in the data
set assuming that a tree ID is unique so
I see that created at yeah that looks
like when it was probably when it was
recorded I'm guessing they're all in
2015 by the name of the data set and we
also have dammit we're definitely gonna
look at this a bit more but I really
still want to stick with the zip code
with asking questions about